大家好，欢迎收听雨光Post。我是惠思，我是Jackie。
这期我和Jackie赶个趟儿聊一下最近最火的一个话题，喇布布。
最近他的新闻特别多，我相信大家都已经看到我连我妈都知道喇布布了。
对，因为很巧的是其实前几天我去一个朋友家聚餐，
然后这个朋友见到我们就特别特别的兴奋地说，
他刚刚从国内买了一端三代的喇布布，
然后就在等着他从国内转运到巴黎，
然后他跟我们说他买的时候在德务上的价格是3699，
买完之后他就那几天都很兴奋，
就是时不时的会打开手机去搜一下看看现在的行情售价，
然后有一会儿就会涨了几十块，一会儿涨了一百块，
就会觉得心里很爽很兴奋的那种，很有趣。
这个很像我最近买黄金的体会。
对，其实有点像哦，就你接着听下去，
结果就是又过了几天嘛，然后我就问他说，
你这个喇布布这个股怎么样了，最近的掌势啊什么的，
他就跟我说哎，别提了，都赔了。
就是他几天的时间吧，到今天的时候我再问他，
他说他买的那一端喇布布，
我如今在网上的价格，只有不到两千块钱人民币了。
等于说他基本上是在最高点买了，
然后开心了没几天就遇到了这个泡马特开始大量放货，
然后就是就这陪在里面了嘛，我觉得非常的有趣。
就这个事情让我最惊讶的点是我的这个朋友啊，
他本来不是喇布布的客群的，
就是他竟然会买，我会觉得很吃惊，对。
因为在我印象当中他完全不是那种小玩具的客群，
你看他不喜欢可爱的东西啊，
然后也不看动漫不玩游戏，
他不像我可能我半只脚还踏在这个圈子里，
最主要的是他之前甚至完全get不到这种虚拟的形象，
他能和人产生情感连接，
比如说他看到我们去买一些模型啊，
或者家里去放的手办的话，
他会表示非常的不理解，
所以我就问他嘛，
我说你怎么会突然想起买喇布补了，
而且是大费周章的那种，
因为巴黎排队现在很难，
他就是从国内去买，
完了寄过来嘛，
然后他给出的答案是，
因为他看到网上很多人都在说，
他的朋友圈也很多人都在说，
然后他就借机去看了一下，
然后了解一下这个价格，
就发现这个价格当时一直在蒙涨，
然后他就想着说，
这个东西其实也没有很贵，
基本上还都是日常可以支出的那个范围内嘛，
所以就想着说，
拿出点钱去参与一下这个时代吧，
跟国内的时代同频了，
对，跟整个世界的同频了嘛，
因为现在大家应该也知道，
就之前在外网TikTok，
就是开了布布的盲盒，
就已经成为了一个流量密码那个样子，
所以他确实在国外也是非常火的。
其实我这边也是，
就是我现在就是前两天，
我还约朋友出来嘛，好久没见了，
然后发现他的微信头像已经换成了喇布布，
他是那种好多好多年不换微信头像的人。
哦，是的，就是就是这么有影响力，
然后还有另外一个朋友，
就最近刷朋友圈也能看到，
他说他买了一个喇布布，
他特别他特别皮，
然后他把那个喇布布那个毛绒那层裙给拆下来了，
然后他发了一张照片，
然后左边是一个赤裸的玩具模型，
然后右边是他那个皮，
然后他配的文是对喇布补去妹了，
觉得好像也没这么可爱。
就是所以这期，
像我们录这期播客，
就录这期喇布，
其实我们准备了大概一周的时间，
然后喇布补的新闻实在是太多了，
就是我们都来不及调整有这种感觉，
一开始最早的信息是，
有一只喇布拍了108万，
然后后来资本市场说，
他们这个创始人王宁现在已经是变成河南首富了，
然后这没过几天又出现了，
他有部分在海外停售，
然后今天我杰克在准备录的时候，
然后又说就是可能政策那边对喇布未来也不是特别友好，
所以就感觉就是这个播客就才10天，
他已经非常密集地展现了喇布补实上实下，
变化极快的一个缩影，
所以一方面就是现在播客难度，
另外一方面这喇布实在是太特殊了，
所以我们这期也不太想说喇布为什么火，
或者说他到底能存活多久，
就是我们这期想从喇布补这个形象背后的文化，
还有他的一些商业操作上去聊，
以及从IP的角度是不是有价值，
那我想先问一下杰克，
你觉得喇布补他和我们印象中的哪个IP是最像的？
这个其实特别特别难说，
因为我觉得怎么说呢，
就是截止到现在为止的话，
可能我们能看到喇布补他在进入到一个转向的阶段，
就是他要从一个初代的网红样的状态，
他看怎么能够让他长红变成一个经典IP，
他其实是在面临这个选择的阶段，
那如果说这种IP的玩法的话，
我可能最先想到的是保可梦，
因为其实这里可以讲一个就是小故事吧，
也不能算小故事，
其实很多人都知道的，
就是泡马特当年在日本有尝试去开店，
然后去进入日本市场的，
然后但是最后的结果不是很好，
因为最开始，比如说行业内的人，
他们会判断日本的这个IP行业，
他的高度成熟，
就是在这个点上是走得很深的，
然后所以当年泡马特先出海，
是选了日本的这个地方，
然后因为是日本的这种消费的土壤很好，
市场也比较繁荣啊这个样子，
但问题是当时虽然也有这个排队购买的盛况，
却基本上是以外国人，
就是对日本人来说的外国人，
就是其实以国人为主的，
而本地的人其实不是很吃拉布布的这一套，
他一个是因为他不吃拉布布的这个外形，
另外一个就是拉布布的这个背景故事，
对于他们来说是很单薄的，
他没有办法从日本这种一众强大的本土IP里去争得一片天地，
所以说回来这一套逻辑，
如果我们说一个把他玩得很开的大神的话，
我会第一个想到的就是宝可梦，
他是特别特别有代表性的，
因为宝可梦本身他就是日本的国宝级的IP，
然后这个IP本身的那种庞大，
就是以及背后的他的背景故事啊，
然后还有他的深度啊他不同的玩法啊，
就是让他我觉得是当之无愧的成为了全球最吸睛的一个IP，
就从动漫到游戏，
对再到卡牌形象，
然后什么的这种，
就是如果说让我个人去断言的话，
我觉得宝可梦不死，
因为他的维度太丰富了，
就已经深入到文化层面了，
这个我忽悠一下Jackie，
因为之前其实我当时在自由公司做过一个主题乐园，
就是研究IP的，
然后当时我们就是做了全世界范围内的调研，
就是这些IP的调研，
其实最吸睛的确实是宝可梦，
然后他的自从诞生以来，
他的吸睛值是100个billion，
1000亿美金，
然后他是冠军全球的。
所以就是说如果说IP的话，
我第一个会想到的是宝可梦这种，
然后第二个我能想到的这种IP的玩法吧，
其实是Sanrio，
就是Hello Kitty,。
然后Melody什么的这个公司，
他跟宝可梦这种一开始就有故事宇宙之称的IP不同，
Sanrio的形象大部分是在初期，
是以那种可爱无害的形象，
然后出现在一些低价的日常用品当中的，
比如说小朋友都可以去支付的文剧，
什么小钱包等等，
他会进入到你的那个童年的小快乐里面，
所以他是从这种细微的地方去培养他的受众对他的喜爱，
然后逐渐的是这个情感连接，
越来越强，
去立住他的IP，
当然这种方式我觉得他也有自己的局限性了，
他最大的局限性可能就是价格的天花板吧，
因为我们可以想象一下，
比如说像Hello Kitty，
因为我们小的时候虽然不在日本，
但是也会用Hello Kitty，
包括什么西瓜太郎这种东西对吧，
但是当我们长大了之后，
我们有更多的钱去负担，
去购买这些东西的时候，
如果他价格过高，
你去提价，
他其实反而会变成一种反视，
对,
他就是这种小东西嘛，
而且他也是甚至有一种，
我之前看到就说Hello Kitty，
他是一种母女都喜欢的小东西，
也没有涨价很多的这种超强情感连接，
跨越太多年了，
Hello Kitty长红50年了,。
而且我会觉得三流其实现在也在担心背景故事这个点，
因为现在这个数字时代，
他的传播速度太快了，
而且本身这个商品的生产，
也是有很大的进步，
而且会变得很快的，
就在我们当下这个时代，
所以就说三流其实也在尝试，
去填充旗下IP的一些故事线，
这样他才能抓住新一代的小朋友，
对对对，
会有比如说Hello Kitty，
其实也是有自己的动画系列的，
他其实是在越来越多的填充这种设定，
不然的话，
我觉得他也容易被新一代人去抛弃，
因为以前我们接触信息，
可能是看，
我的铜桌买了一个漂亮的小笔带，
但现在的话，
你刷一晚上的抖音，
可能你比铜桌的那个。
盖的信息的速度，
真的是要快很多了。
但是这个，
和我一开始，
我对于这个Hello Kitty的了解，
其实有点不一样，
其实我还申罢了一下，
就是Hello Kitty,。
她的这个策略，
Hello Kitty和La Bu Bu,。
特别像的一点，
就是她都是一个没有故事的，
但受人欢迎的形象，
所以从这一点来讲，
他们是非常相似的，
但是,
相一点其实，
刚才Jackie说了，
就是她走路线，
其实是全渠道授权，
就是大家可以猜一猜，
就是Hello Kitty,。
诞生50年来，
她们的授权合作大概有多少个，
什么量级？
不知道，
我觉得天上繁星的大多吧，
对对对，
就是这个量级大概是5万个，
然后覆盖100多个国家，
就是可能这个没有什么概念，
但具体来说，
它是每年新增2000个授权，
新授权，
这大概是每天都有6-8个新合作，
就是非常非常夸张，
就我感觉她商务能力一定很强，
她是什么路线，
就是她本身其实不是一个玩偶，
她是个小图案，
她就是本质上和你衣服上的一个，
印花纹路是一个概念，
但是她能够做到这一点，
就是Hello Kitty的形象，
就是她没有嘴嘛，
其实我小的时候一直都没有发现，
只是觉得所有的小伙伴都在用Hello Kitty，
直到最近才觉得没有嘴，
或者说她重点的，
不是她少一个五官，
而是说她没有表情，
她不会笑，
不会哭，
是一个完全中立的形象，
可以说是一个IP界的小瑞士，
所以她能够印在各种物品上，
所以其实为了Hello Kitty有一个。
特别有趣的话题，
是她的奇葩授权，
比如说，
因为她授权太多了嘛，
比如当时在台湾市场，
就瞄准了可爱葬礼的需求，
将Hello Kitty的形象授权过棺材，
还有一点就是，
因为她没有嘴，
所以等于没有立场，
所以她是绝对的政治安全，
比如在2014年的时候，
Hello Kitty曾经和俄罗斯的。
军用罐头场合作，
就猛男必卑是吗，
还不知道为什么，
这个还挺反插猛的，
但是就是，
因为是军用相关嘛，
所以你说Hello Kitty的支持战争嘛，
但是她只是图案，
你好像不能说什么，
但是如果你设想一下，
在军用设施和美国队长联名，
是不是被解读为政治战队？
所以她有一种极端的中立性，
确实,
所以就是，
这个设场是非常坚持，
这个无嘴无立场的设计的，
在80年代的时候，
她在总部日本，
美国分公司曾经提议，
给Hello Kitty加嘴,。
遭到了设长的怒斥，
说这不是迪斯尼，
然后也有日本员工，
曾经提议给Hello Kitty做动画，
然后被这个设长否决，
她认为故事会杀死她，
这个就是为什么，
刚才采提说到，
她后来做动画了，
我刚才顺手查了一下，
她确实在2024年的时候，
做了一个动画片，
她可能未来也需要面临一个转型，
但确实至少在非常多年，
就是过去的基本上，
将近50年的时间中，
她一直是坚持，
没有立场，
没有故事设定的。
对,
所以是一个很近的事情，
她才开始去让她长出嘴来，
我是记得我又看到过Hello Kitty的动画，
因为里面她要跟人说话，
她不可能还是打赋予的那种感觉，
然后如果说到这种，
没有故事背景的IP的话，
就不得不提到我分类的，
第三类的一个代表，
我觉得应该很多人都知道，
可能可以叫做时代的眼泪了，
就是那个Beer Break，
也就是我们俗话两个暴力熊，
他可以说是走了另外一个极端吧，
就是他没有背景故事，
而且应该至今也是完全没有背景故事的，
但是暴力熊他能活起来，
是因为他有一个另外的玩法，
就是他那时尚加艺术品，
然后去混搭出一个逻辑，
首先是需要与一般的这种消费品区分开来的，
所以这一类的IP，
他要非常讲究他的稀缺性，
以及他本身的形象，
是不能过于幼稚同志化的，
像小孩会喜欢的那种，
可爱什么，
是要非常谨慎去选择的，
因为他要维持这个创作作为一个基底，
要有很高的宽容度，
然后才能去完成跨界，
联名,
然后能衍生出那种千人千面的可能性，
我们再说回来这个Laboub的话，
其实可以设想一下，
如果Laboub走这条路，
是天然是有一点点难的，
因为他的形象是比较幼稚化的，
另外就是他自己的那个面部特征，
特别的明显，
就是有一个说法，
就是大家会数，
所以Laboub是9颗牙，
然后还有什么大眼睛，
然后什么肌膜膜有尾巴，
什么之类的这些点，
就是他的外貌特征，
其实是有一些限定的，
所以这个时候，
如果再去尝试做二创联名，
比如说跟艺术家合作，
跟时尚品牌合作的时候，
就很容易陷入到说，
不能只是简单的换皮，
但是又不能改变太多，
让别人看不出是Laboub的这样的一个困境当中，
不过鲍利熊，
就为什么我刚才说，
他也是时代的眼泪呢，
就是他红了很多年，
但是现在他也有自己的一个局限性，
而他局限性最主要的一个点，
应该也是像Laboub这种IP会遇到，
甚至正在面临的，
一个是审美疲劳，
然后第二个就是假货的市场，
会对他的冲击非常非常大，
因为你的那个独一无二的标签，
身份标签就失效了，
然后他的稀缺性也失效了，
自然就是会被曾经那些，
花大价钱去购买他的拥护者，
所以遗弃。
这可能是潮玩天生一种矛盾吧，
因为收藏品的话，
比如说艺术家画一幅画，
因为是手工画的，
你一定每一个都是不一样的，
但是一旦一个潮玩，
它是一个工厂流水线生产出来的，
哪怕就是售卖方，
它再去限定有多少个，
就是你很难避免不出验品。
对，所以说，
如果我们再回头看现在的Laboub的话，
我觉得他如果想走下去，
他会跟无论是三流，
还是说想赶去走bokemon，
然后迪士尼的那种玩法，
就是他必须要去想办法去做一些升级，
当然他如果想走暴力熊，
就还是时尚加高价，
然后限量的这个路径也是可以的，
但是不知道能不能走得通，
就是但是无论如何，
他其实升级最大的难点是在于，
他要去选择一个方式，
因为现在这个阶段，
Laboub的受众面其实是很广的，
最初的Laboub，
他是以一小圈，
比如说喜欢超玩，喜欢盲和，
而且真心喜欢这个形象的这种爱好者为主，
然后慢慢的就会有更多的大众，
他会需求说，
我在我包上挂一个，
可爱的小玩偶，
他有很强的这种社交货币的感觉，
然后包括受到了什么Lisa的影响，
然后还有像我朋友这种，
他是都拿他去报知这种，
就是现在的就真的很广，
所以说，
接下来泡马特，
他如何去做Laboub，
他的一个升级是要很小心的，
不然你选了其中一条路，
可能会得罪其他人，
但是如果说你去混合的话，
又会使这个产品缺少了那种纯粹的动因，
然后进入到一个非常尴尬的地带，
不过从最近的消息来看，
这个是我今天早上刚刷到的，
我觉得泡马特肯定是选择的迪士尼那条路，
因为他们已经成立了一个影视部门，
就是专门用来，
就是设计新的动画剧集，
什么这种方式去加强他的内容层的基建，
我觉得比较有趣的其实是，
当泡马特是涂作迪士尼的时候，
就是给故事增加厚度，
但其实反过来，迪士尼其实是为了适应中国市场的碎片画，
还有社交性，还特意推了林纳贝尔这个角色，
不知道大家还记不记得，
迪士尼他自己造了一个眉库，
上一代女明星，
迪士尼也开始拥抱这种玩法，
但是为了拥有中国市场，
因为这个角色他是在上海迪士尼首发的，
其实他当时的定位是非常具体的，
他的目的就是为了女性游客拍照互动时能有一个陪伴角色，
但是这不能是一个简单那种套着头的那种大型玩偶，
就是他要有一种比较让有记忆点的互动，
比如说林纳贝尔会撩裙子，
会插腰吵架，
就是简单说，
迪士尼他尝试用人设替代故事，
其实某种程度上老布布奇尔也是，
他有一个人设，
就是一个小妖怪，
就是有点叛逆，
他有一个特殊的人设，
但你不能说的没有故事，
因为他毕竟出自一个汇本，
但他的故事的厚度远远不够像迪士尼这么厚重，
所以迪士尼其实也在反向的去做这件事，
然后还查了一下迪士尼高管的表态，
他说林纳贝尔证明了IP可以跳过内容，
直接靠人设和体验变先，
但仅限中国市场，
因为林纳贝尔在欧美这种传统市场，
遇冷,
他在2023年巴黎，
还有奥兰多，
想复制这套中国的版本法，
结果大家不认同迪士尼做这件事情，
他们觉得我到了迪士尼，
就是为了这些回忆，
或者为了故事来的，
你做这件事情，
其实是背离了迪士尼内容为王的传统，
当然这个只是在其他市场，
在中国这一套其实吃得还满开的，
所以就是只卖人设也可以，
但是包含林纳贝尔，
他的IP周期，
其实料想也不会太长，
就是你要不要挣块钱这个问题，
但是肯定马特之所以成立这个饮食工作室，
他就是想要做内容，
肯定是花大家钱了嘛，
所以他做内容能不能行，
就是我觉得从他的品牌基因来讲，
跑到马特他本质是一个渠道上，
他是最核心的竞争理，
其实是铺货，还有就是选址，
你可以理解，
就是强于铺货处理创作，
还有他的供应链管理，
都是他的强项，
所以他这种渠道商的品牌基因。
和IP公司的4A方式是很不一样的，
因为IP公司他核心竞争理是讲故事，
然后做用户情感连接，
甚至是长期复环的IP，
但是在这里我并不是认为说，
像蓝不武这种，
就是大家肯定都知道，
他其实是一种强数据驱动的公司，
因为对他来讲，
如果不是蓝不武红，
那也是另外一个IP红，
比如说上一代的毛利，
因为他其实本质上是通过小范围的测试，
然后如果效果不错，
这个都是数据告诉他的嘛，
然后他就会加码，
然后生产，
然后在门店中把，
他想推的这个超晚，
然后放到更中间的位置，
然后资源上给他更多的倾斜，
比如蓝不武后来在上海，
然后还给这个艺术家开办了画展，
肯定吃掉他很多资源，
所以他其实是在走测试放大，
然后迭代，
然后这样一个非常商业化的路径，
所以他本身是一个数据驱动的公司，
但我并不认为数据驱动，
就是在内容行业有原罪，
就是我觉得也不能这么理解，
就是我觉得如果说，
与其说他想做迪斯尼，
倒不如说我觉得，
他在对标中国的这个图上，
他可以反而参考的是国内的网纹老大岳文，
因为岳文他作为一个互联网公司，
就是他本质也是一个渠道商，
他就做平台嘛，
就是比如说他头部IP嘛，
就是庆余年，
不知道Jackie知不知道，
知道知道知道，
我前两天还有重新看了一遍，
真的,
你是先看的书还是看的电视剧啊，
我不看书，
我不怎么看网文，
但是我会看电视剧，
包括我现在会刷短剧，
是是是，
你看他这个属于就把你给破了嘛，
相当于他IP做的很成功，
他本来是一个网文，
结果他变成了一个电视剧，
就是他其实当时有一个细节，
就是因为他寄来大量的用户反馈嘛，
当年其实是邀请书粉来票选，
到底选谁做男主角，
然后73%的书有票选了，
就是现在的这个人，
应该叫张若云吧，
然后当年其实是没有找任何顶流的，
所以他其实是能够通过数据，
获得很多对于这个作品，
怎么说呢，
其实你可以理解为对未来市场一个湿水，
但是你说月文他成功孵化了青年这样的IP，
你可以理解为他一开始只做授权，
就是泡马特这个模式嘛，
然后他现在其实是十打十做内容，
然后变成了一个制片公司，
其实他也经历了一个非常痛苦的过程，
因为月文之前曾经做，
比如说不知道，
就是我们的听优们数不数去，
比如说像斗破仓穷，
还有全职高手，
然后他的剧板都失败了，
都失败了，
然后后来他瓦剿了好莱坞失效团队，
然后也做了一些比如说和中系北电合作，
就是建了一个就是编剧训练营，
这样一个班，
然后来华重金补课，
可以可以就是可以这么讲，
而且他还有我非常幸运的一点，
就是当时他改变成电视剧的时候，
锁定了头部编剧，
这个人叫王卷，
就是业内有一句话叫做，
如果男品IP铺接的话，
就找王卷，
就关于为什么这个人是旧场网，
我们不展开，
但是就是他的，
就是这个意思就是说，
如果要是没有一个话腐朽为神奇的编剧，
或者说青云年，
当时没有找到这个人，
青云年的这个影视IP还是出不来，
所以泡马特如果他现在想去，
他是一个就是强数据的公司，
如果他现在也有钱了嘛，
他上市了，
当然虽然他的股价会波动，
他肯定是有钱的，
他如果想砸钱影视的话，
我觉得也无可厚非吧，
但是他肯定是先天不足的，
还是我们刚才说的原因，
因为他本质是一个渠道商，
就是他能不能像月文一样硬上，
从这种平台型的公司，
或者说渠道商，
转型成一个制片公司，
就我觉得是非常非常有挑战的，
也就是说，
他本身他不是天才，
他不具备这样的天赋，
和这样的基因，
除非他变成一个地才，
然后就是各种资源，
各种运气都堆上，
那可能比较有可能。
其实我们刚才聊了好几个IP，
其实大致给总结出，
这样几个录书，
就是我们刚才聊了最多的其实是，
不不能就是给他的IP填充故事，
通过这个方法，
能够让他这个IP，
能够跨越更长的周期，
感觉是比较难的。
然后还有就是，
比如说Hello Kitty嘛，
Hello Kitty的话,。
它是靠这种拳区道授权去做的，
但是它要中立，
但是,
不不不，好像确实没有这块的基因。
还有就是和暴力熊嘛，
其实说到和暴力熊的对比，
就是我想就是界定一下，
因为我还是比较喜欢分类雪这件事，
就我觉得他其实和暴力熊是非常像的，
因为他们都属于炒碗，
当然他们的玩法定位不同，
就所以我觉得，
他们是比较像的，
想要跟大家，
就是确认一下，
就是什么是炒碗，
就不知道大家有没有想过炒碗是啥，
Jackie,
你觉得炒碗的定义应该是什么？
啊,
我一直觉得炒碗这个，
就对于我来说，
因为我是做艺术品市场的嘛，
我觉得炒碗相当于，
艺术品市场的一个降级，
就是它会用一些比较，
对，它会用一些比较快销，
比较更大众情绪的点，
然后非常图像化的东西，
去先创造一个IP，
或者说是一种风格其实也可以，
然后,
把这个东西去限量，
让它变得稀缺，
然后卖更高的价格，
其实它本身是在，
搜罗艺群跟艺术品收藏一样的，
小众玩家的，
但是他们前提是，
这群人得不缺钱，
它跟达布布就是，
在这个点上，
会让我觉得，
还不是特别的像，
因为达布布还是比较像是那种，
就是收割大众的那种嘛，
因为包括它其实最基本的定价，
并不是很贵，
它一个盲盒的价格，
在欧洲可能是二三十欧，
对于我们来说就还好，
然后在国内的话，
我若没记错，
应该是99一个盲盒，
大概是这样，
对对对，
这个价格它就是你，
它限量当然好，
当然它不限量的话，
其实,
大家是买得起的，
问题你喜欢就买就好了，
只是说达布布，
它现在逐渐发展发展之后，
它进入到了一个，
理智的审视阶段，
所以大家会说，
它如果卖到那么高的价格的话，
就脱离了它最开始的那个定价，
是不是我们就可以拿它，
跟保利熊去做对比了？
你是这么看待的，
因为它相当于，
艺术市场的降温期，
以及它的价位要摆在那里，对吧？
就是对这个潮玩的定义有，
然后就是我看了也看了一些资料嘛，
它是这个样子的，
它角度不一样，
就首先第一点，
它是需要艺术家，
或者是设计师背书的，
那达布布就是也算，
因为它的这个画师，
它的创作者是龙家生，
他本人也获过，
博罗尼的奖，
这个如果我们的听友中有宝妈，
可能会对这个比较了解，
因为它是做绘本的，
意大利的一个奖项，
然后达布布是他绘本中的一个小配角，
所以艺术家背书算是有了，
然后宝绿熊的话，
其实,
如果他做联名的话，
也会标注艺术家，
所以这是第一点，
就是艺术家设计师背书，
第二点的话呢，
就是他有二级市场，
可以理解为，
可以炒，可以收藏，
就是有一点点小的金融属性了，
比如说他可能在咸鱼上，
或者是通过拍卖行，
但,
不布他还是，
就是咸鱼嘛，
他也不太贵，
这是你的好朋友，
每天看着他那个价格，
长长跌跌，
筷子的来源，
我觉得真的，
就是他和金融已经很像了，
就是他和比如说我买黄金啊，
或者什么的，
就心态一模一样，
有二级市场，
会变化啊，
他和原来的定价已经不一样了，
第三个就是说，
因为就是他需要他可以炒，
所以他是需要维持稀缺性的，
那,
喇布布他的，
泡玛特给他人为制造的隐藏款比例，
是1比144,
这是一个什么概念呢，
就是说购买者有0.69%的概率，
去抽到这个隐藏款，
这真的是人为去做这件事情嘛，
那像比如说像鲍利熊，
他那个大号的那个香奈尔和鲍利熊，
就是那个很大的那个，
他会标注说啊，
这个全球有只有500个，
他通过这种方式去，
去强调他的稀缺性，
所以这个是我觉得，
他们都算是，
炒完品类的，
就是至少这个概念上是符合的，
虽然他的这个明显定价阶级是不一样的，
但是肯定相一点嘛，
就刚才说的，
他不好联名啊，
这个不不，
但是,
就是我也查了一下鲍利熊的定位哦，
就是现在我们对他的认知，
其实是，
他还搞联名嘛，
和设置品，
但其实这个联名，
真的是无心插流流成音，
就是我们这个时候，
就是再当开一笔，
聊一聊这个，
这个鲍利熊，
就是当时，
其实是，
就是这个艺术家，
然后他本人，
其实也有一个，
炒完形象，
就也挺有名的，
不知道大家知不知道，
就是有一点龙褲，
有点像这个，
米老鼠，
但是他那个两个眼睛，
都是两个叉，
就是这么一个形象，
他在东京旅行的时候，
是在储窗里，
就是商店的储窗里，
看到这只熊，
他觉得就是，
这种高六百的设计，
刚好画他那个，
标志性的叉叉眼，
所以主动提出来啊，
我想合作，
那当时鲍利熊这个公司的社长，
其实没太大信心，
只做了五百个，
但是后来他发现，
他的二级市场表现，
实在是太好了，
就是二手，
二手的那个价格，
暴涨了十倍，
所以这个社长，
他就,
也算是一种商业动产吧，
就发现了，
这个鲍利熊，
他的价值不是设计，
而是说可定制性，
从此他才走上了，
这个和设置品联名，
的,
这样的一个，
战略定位，
但是,
就是一个冷之手，
就是,
鲍利熊在被这个COS，
发现联名之前，
其实他的定位，
是做办公桌上的，
职人玩具，
有没有，
有没有感觉，
所以他可以价个笔，
说的那种感觉，
不是,
他也有具体的功效，
就是说，
如果你想解压的话，
因为他不是可拆卸的吗，
你可以在那儿拆拆卸卸，
就是,
但是,
他的这个定位，
这个社长，
其实也蛮精明的，
就是说，
暴利熊他当，
但是在90年代嘛，
然后那个时候，
97年金融危机之后，
整个日本，
或者全球的经济，
很低迷，
职场压力大，
社畜嘛，
我们现在说牛马，
人家那个时候，
日本有社畜呀，
就开始疯狂加班，
那,
社畜唯一可以掌控的，
就是自己的办公桌，
所以,
那个时候，
的社畜和我们现在的牛马，
心态其实，
是有异曲统工之妙的，
他们需要表面服从企业文化，
比如说，
你想,
日本那个市场环境，
你得鞠躬，
得穿西装，
但是其实，
他内心特别渴望，
一种个性化的表达，
就发现了这个需求，
说,
这些职人，
他们需要一件，
不被上司批评，
但是能让同事，
会心一笑的东西，
也就是说，
他符合职场，
低调叛逆的需求，
就是我觉得，
好多人现在买了，
不如尤其上班族买，
我觉得有点这种感觉，
就是他也是一种，
某种程度上的，
就是,
叛逆,
是的,
就是后来，
这个数据也有印证嘛，
在2003年的时候，
有这样的市场调研，
说,
大概73%的暴力熊，
买家都称，
同事夸过我的熊，
就是这种感觉，
大家就是，
我懂潮流，
但是我不上头，
后来,
暴力熊嘛，
他在发现了，
这个联名款的，
这个优势之后，
其实他，
已经不怎么做，
这个职人文化，
因为他其实，
一直需要变相嘛，
他现在，
只在日本本土推，
这个,
就是,
面向职人的，
这种基础款，
毕竟,
就是日本，
还是有这个社会，
他存在的，
但只是象征性的，
但是所有，
包括他的产能，
还有营销，
都已经，
转向了联名，
因为啥呢，
因为联名款，
贡献的毛利率，
已经超过了95%。
嗯,
其实他潮完，
会随着时代的变化去，
不停地去，
寻找他的定位的。
嗯,
但确实，
比如说，
如果啦，
不不,
他现在，
可能有点，
像这个，
职人玩具啊，
就是,
或者说，
命中了，
我们这个时代的，
某种情绪，
毕竟,
人家这个阿里也在先了，
就是他，
后来,
转向了，
设置品联名，
因为那个东西，
更长钱，
但是他现在，
又走不了，
所以,
所以他，
会满焦虑的。
嗯,
但你刚才说的，
就是,
第一个点，
我特别认可，
就是,
我觉得，
哪不不得，
他的爆红，
完全是一场运气，
就是,
你刚才说的那种，
呃,
先是水，
然后,
包括他，
感觉在，
然后,
但是第二个点，
我是觉得，
哪不不，
他现在能火，
其实还是，
多多少少，
有一点点，
时代特性的。
因为,
嗯,
比如说，
现,
现上我们，
虽然,
就是,
很多人都在讲啊，
他,
比如说，
从北欧，
的一些神话啊，
或者是精灵啊，
作为他的这个，
形象来源，
但是我去，
看了一下，
其实是没有特别明确的那种，
能体系的那种，
其实是没有的，
他更多的是，
这个创作者，
他曾经生活在欧洲，
然后,
他自己的一些，
个人情绪的，
具象化的表达，
只是说，
他可能受到了，
这种,
北欧的，
什么的一些影响，
等等的，
所以他本身的，
文化,
是非常模糊的，
但这个点，
反而就是，
给了,
哪不不，
一个更大的，
投射空间，
使得无论你是，
在欧洲的一个，
小年轻，
还是一个，
在中国的上班族，
还是你是，
美国的一个，
白人,
贵妇,
你其实都可以买他，
就是因为你，
都可以，
找到一个方式去，
投射他，
或者说，
至少去，
接纳他，
就我们可以看，
Labou的这个外形，
他虽然说，
他叫做The Monster,。
他是那种，
小怪兽的感觉，
但其实，
你从他身上，
是感受不到，
来自外界的，
威胁的，
他反而会是，
一种,
自我情绪的，
一个外化，
就是很像那个，
那个那个，
头脑特工队，
对对对，
他就很像，
头脑特工队，
里面的那种，
你人化的那个感觉，
他其实反而会，
就不但不会让你，
感到威胁，
反而会让你，
觉得很，
很舒服，
很亲密的那种感觉，
然后另外一个，
就是,
呃,
我不知道大家有没有，
感受到，
其实在疫情之后，
毛绒类的产品，
或者说，
带有一点点，
毛绒属性的东西，
是会被这个市场，
接受度很高的，
啊,Jelly Cat,。
对对对，
Jelly Cat,。
就是一个很典型的例子，
然后,
呃,
包括如果是，
有一些做玩具的，
厂商啊，
或者什么的，
他们都会去说，
哎,
现在这个，
毛绒产业，
是,
其实是可以去做一做的，
等等的，
当然这个，
已经很长时间了，
这并不是一个，
非常新的事情，
所以,
我会觉得，
嗯,
从他的身上，
也是可以看到一些，
呃,
兴奋嘛，
然后,
呃,
还有一个点，
我不知道，
蕙斯妮有没有关注到，
就是其实，
我们在讲这个，
呃,
潮玩也吧，
IP也吧,
然后,
包括喇布布，
本身也吧，
他都跟香港这个城市，
很相关，
啊，对对对对对对，
是的,
这个是我特别有感触的一点，
就是,
就一开始，
啊,
大家我就去查喇布，
说,
就是,
你觉得这件事，
特别合理，
因为,
香港在我的印象中，
就是总和潮人，
潮玩有关，
什么城关西啦，
什么,
就是,
他们穿的也很潮，
然后,
好像也很爱，
就是买这些东西，
所以,
确实,
感觉和，
香港有，
非常密切的关系，
嗯,
对,
因为,
其实在这个，
潮玩这个领域当中，
或者说，
他都不光是潮玩了，
是潮流文化这个领域当中，
香港他，
一个非常非常重要的角色的，
一直以来，
一方面，
他是有，
就是,
比如说，
对于我们中国人来说，
或者对于，
甚至全世界人来说吧，
他是有，
就是,
跨文化桥梁这样的一个角色，
比如说，
他会引入日本的，
呃,
潮流风尚的一些东西，
然后,
包括西方的一些潮流，
他会把他们，
第一个，
先到香港，
然后,
做一个跳板，
到内地这个样子，
而根本上，
他又直跟在中国的文化传承上，
然后,
这种折中的风格，
那就是，
为了后来的这种，
潮玩审美啊，
潮流审美啊，
其实打开的是，
打开了一条通道的，
对,
然后,
更重要的一个原因，
我觉得是，
因为,
香港文化和市场，
他有一个，
怎么说呢，
他有一个混乱属性的，
对,
而他的节奏非常快，
嗯,
然后,
这种条件，
就会,
给香港当地，
带来一种张力，
他会使一些，
呃,
也许是，
意识到的一些情绪啊，
什么的，
他会在香港，
这种地方，
他会快速的，
显形,
而且,
变得非常浓缩，
就是我补充一点，
就是你说，
就是他这种杂肉嘛，
就,
为什么是香港嘛，
就是,
呃,
他其实是街头，
艺术,
还有金融的，
一场三角链，
你知道，
香港有一条，
叫河里活街，
就,
大概就是，
好莱坞吧，
好莱坞，
就是这种，
就是,
他那条街上，
在香港，
他的拍卖行，
会为他，
进行加持，
像苏博比，
还有加持德香港，
就会定期，
举办潮玩专场，
那,
他们其实在，
这种拍卖行，
在,
呃,
中国大陆，
因为中国大陆，
其实是有这种，
文物的，
红线管制，
以及这种，
呃,
就外汇资金，
流向的限制，
所以,
他们哪怕，
想要面向中国市场，
也会选在香港，
去做这个拍卖行的拍卖的话，
比如说，
我们刚才说的那种，
呃,
潮玩金融化，
还有就是，
设置品联名嘛，
香港设置品也很多嘛，
就是,
我们对香港的一些印象，
所以,
他是这三种东西，
你可以理解为，
产业型的也好，
文化型的也罢，
是,
这三样东西，
离个杂交，
混合三角连，
所以,
潮玩确实在那里，
呃,
诞生在那里，
就是,
无可厚非啦，
嗯,
就从我的视角来讲，
他,
天然有一个，
呃,
香港是存在一种，
源于身份认同的摇摆，
哈哈,
对对对，
对对,
因为香港，
香港,
它作为一个就是，
全球化的一个城市嘛，
其实当地的年轻人，
一方面就是被，
刚才卉斯说的这种，
全球资本的红流，
真的是，
一个浪一个浪的在拍的，
然后另外一方面，
他们其实也承受着一种，
怎么说呢，
身份上的模糊性，
因为它存在，
就是,
中港,
这种区别，
或者内陆于香港，
然后,
英国于香港，
还有东西文化的结合，
那这个时候，
其实潮流文化，
它就可以，
成为一种，
低门槛的身份补定，
就是,
你不用，
去表态，
你不是必须要去，
说明白，
表明你的逻辑啊，
你也不用去，
讲清楚，
什么历史，
成因,
然后也不用，
提出任何的解决方案，
其实,
你就只需要，
用一些触手可及，
而且可消费的，
一些小物品，
去,
以物自证，
就可以了，
我们看这个，
潮流文化，
它本身，
呃,
会经常，
会带着，
一点点，
美好,
然后,
又怪弹的这种风格，
潮玩呢，
它又是一种，
混合,
快,
呃,
无故事，
但是有态度，
的特性，
有态度，
其实,
比它有故事背景，
要重要很多，
因为它，
怎么说呢，
就是反传统叙事，
就是,
不要那么重的故事，
我不要你给我说说道道，
呃,
我觉得视觉表达，
比文本表达，
更重要，
我觉得，
极性很重要，
图像比故事重要，
它是这样的一个心理，
所以我们也会，
经常在这个，
潮流玩，
就是,
潮流文化上面，
会看到，
一些,
呃，玩具画呀，
然后儿童画的，
这些,
形象,
比如说，
然后,
但是,
它的身体，
又特别，
又小,
就这种形象，
就是很吃得开的，
因为它本质，
是将,
呃,
成年人的，
世界的一些责任，
和,
焦虑,
去投射到一个，
怎么说呢，
就是一个，
小孩子般的，
一个空壳上面的，
然后去达成，
一种,
心理替代，
至少说，
可以稍微，
逃逸一下，
社会规训吧，
其实,
他们其实，
是有一定的，
那个歌词中，
总有公仔，
我就感觉那个，
潮流玩具，
或者说，
玩偶在他们那儿，
真的很流行，
就是,
他们需要这些东西，
对,
然后,
绝德,
就是,
呃,
其实是安全的，
嗯,
我甚至会认为，
一个娃娃的脸，
就是,
当下火的，
这种玩偶的脸，
它其实，
就是,
刚带年轻人的面相，
它长什么样子，
其实,
那张脸，
就说明了很多问题，
1974年,
对,
它是1974年，
呃,
设计生产出来的，
然后,
它的面部特征，
就是,
像,
刚才惠斯也注意到，
就是,
它没有嘴吧，
然后,
它始终是会给人那种，
静静的，
可爱的，
温顺的，
这种感觉，
呃,
一方面是，
这种中立感吧，
然后,
就是,
因为战后的，
这种,
经济环境当中，
然后一些敏感的东西，
他们其实，
想要成为，
年轻的小女孩，
其实,
是她的主要的，
消费群体，
然后,
当时的，
日本少女，
她会有一个这样的，
一个幻想的，
完美形象，
就是,
顺从,
然后，温柔，
然后,
可能会，
不那么发生，
然后,
但是,
她可以始终保持，
很可爱，
所以,
年轻人，
会把这种，
就是,
社会对他们的，
期待的，
懂事啊，
不添麻烦的，
这种女孩子的形象，
集体主义下的，
一种,
亲近感。
其实,
这个Sally,。
我一开始一直以为，
其实,
是一个动画品牌，
但不是的，
她是一个，
离品杂货铺，
就是,
和我们小的时候，
印象是一样的，
她卖文具，
卖粘贴，
然后,
当时这个社长，
瞄准的，
其实是，
高中女生，
这个消费群体，
然后,
她认为那个时候，
这个群体，
是,
怎么说，
是最有消费能力的，
就为什么，
她是一桶飞，
然后,
家长开始有钱了，
所以她有，
这种,
预算一出，
然后,
另外一方面，
那个时候，
开始少子化，
就有点像我们这边的，
独生子女，
然后,
这些钱都给，
一个人花，
这零花钱比较多，
另外就是，
那个时候，
女生上高中的，
比例在上升，
就是,
大家都知道，
日本的男女，
地位不平等，
关键非常严重，
那个时候，
就是,
大量的女孩，
那Hello Kitty,。
最早是给，
零钱包做设计的，
然后,
社长给这个，
设计师的指令，
是,
化个可爱的动物，
他说什么，
猫啊,
狗啊,
熊啊,
都可以，
成本要低，
不能让这个，
Hello Kitty,。
这个简单的，
形象太复杂，
要不然会增加，
印刷费，
我和深游体会，
这种东西，
对对对，
然后,
你知道，
这个设计师，
本人,
也是交作业的心态，
因为,
所以有两个关键事实，
第一个就是，
Hello Kitty,。
她诞生的时候，
其实，是没有IP野心的，
纯粹是，
试试,
哪个图案好买，
其实,
和炮马特，
之间有，
一去同用之妙，
然后,
社长的最初计划，
也是,
如果六个月不热，
想要立刻换下一个图案，
其实,
这种数据思维，
在哪个年代都一样，
只不过，
你用的工具，
还有数据样本，
就是不一样的，
然后,
就是,
这个设计中，
赚了多少钱，
嗯,
到现在吗，
还是说当年，
哦,
你看,
你这个一看，
就是一个IP思维，
就是,
你觉得，
她是不是能分成呀，
嗯,
所以,
她能有一个累，
哦,
她当年，
是一次性买断的，
哦,
她只收到了一次性稿费，
五千五百日元，
啊,
这么低啊，
对,
她现在，
长子都毁清了，
对,
太低了呀，
就是,
她其实那个时候，
没有什么IP概念嘛，
也或者说，
当时她也没想着做IP，
她只是，
就是,
各种图案之一，
但没想到这个东西，
真的爆火，
因为那个无嘴的设计，
就是Hello Kitty,。
她这种图像，
驱动,
就是因为她没有灵魂嘛，
就是她可以复制嘛，
嗯,
就是,
在我看来，
她是非常难复制的，
因为,
她其实是有时代红利的，
然后这种时代红利，
叠加了Hello Kitty,。
在诞生的时候，
就是没有竞争对手呀，
嗯,
就是这样一款，
产品能够活，
而且,
她当时，
其实一开始，
她的定位其实也很精准，
瞄准的，
就是各种，
就是社会变化中，
就是高中女生，
这个群体，
就是,
这个实在是运气太好了，
或者说，
太有染性了，
所以她很难复制，
而且,
啊,
就是,
三六,
她能够坚持五十年，
不给Hello Kitty,。
不给她加上嘴，
对,
能忍所不能，
对,对,
对,
我觉得这定理，
不是一般人能有的，
反正今天，
聊这些，
我们也不是说，
要去,
诈指,
别人喜欢，
或者是不喜欢，
辣不不，
只是提供一些观点，
然后大家也可以，
在留言里，
或者说，
在听友群里去说一说，
你们,
如何看待，
辣不不，
呃,
她还会不会长，
她会怎么办，
OK,
所以我们今天，
就聊到这里吧，
下期见，
拜拜,